okay so today we're gonna uncomplicated
minute fasting and actually make it very
easy for you okay it's actually quite
simple
I mean intermittent fasting is basically
not eating okay so it's not starving
it's just you're omitting all these
frequent meals it's actually very very
simple but a lot of times people
complicate it they want to know can I
have my supplements yes you can have
your supplements can empty yes you can
have your tea can I drink water yes you
can drink water you can have some coffee
the point is that a true fast is just
water and nothing else okay but if we're
adding supplements or tea or a little
coffee I'm going to still consider that
fasting and you're not going to really
break the fast okay all right so here's
the big thing about in a minute fasting
to make it really really simple you
actually want to let your body dictate
when to feed it okay when to eat and
also how long you're gonna go without
eating so the time may vary because you
only want to eat when you're hungry okay
and then not eat when you're not hungry
and it might sound really simple but
sometimes you have to explain it to
people because at the first hint of a
little slight hunger people just start
eating I'm like that's not what we're
talking about because even in the
morning at 8 o'clock a.m. you have a
hormonal spike of cortisol okay that's
an adrenal hormone that's a stress
hormone that will make you a little
hungry so you may find right in the
morning while I'm hungry and then that
passes and then you're not hungry so
slight hunger is you want to just keep
going ignore that what I'm talking about
is a strong hunger a stomach pains you
started getting lightheaded weak grouchy
okay that means it's time to eat okay
especially in the beginning you're gonna
have this you're gonna feel fine all
this and you're gonna have these
symptoms and that's just a blood sugar
crash so you'll have to just get used to
it but the more and more you do this the
more you're going to go from sugar
burning to fat burning more efficiently
that takes time though okay so another
factor is the estimation of effort it
takes to really get into this hard core
so you're fully in the key downwards
comfortable you have cognitive benefits
you feel focused you have concentration
you're a memory you can actually learn
faster so that's going to happen over
time but for some people it could take
three to four months okay and I'm
talking about weight loss too especially
in your midsection and your blood sugars
it just might take time because your
whole life you've done this way and now
we're trying to undo it and it does take
some time so go into this for the long
haul and just give it time okay
all right the other thing I want to talk
about is how to start this whole thing
the first thing is like let's say for
you're doing all these multiple meals
per day you're doing snacks the first
thing is to lower your carbs okay that's
number one that's automatically gonna
start helping you be less hungry so you
can go longer so now you go three meals
no snacks okay that's the first goal
it's really important to add enough fat
okay to go from one meal to the next
very very important it's also important
to add enough vegetables to also help
you go from one meal to the next a big
mistake that people make is they try to
do this without enough vegetables you
need vegetables for the potassium and
magnesium and the other minerals and
vitamins that help heal insulin
resistance and help lower insulin as
well as the fiber that feeds the
microbes in your gut and that produces
something called butyric acid which
helps insulin resistance it decreases
hunger it helps blood sugars it feeds
the colon cells and it helps your immune
system the combination of good fat and
vegetables is going to help you go from
one node to the next and then just let
your body dictate when to eat so you're
gonna find you can go longer so you skip
the breakfast now you're at two meals a
day and now you start to squish those
together slowly okay let your body tell
you when to do it
to the point where you're not hungry
anymore so then you just do one meal a
day a lot of people are doing this but
you want to work up to it and just kind
of keep it really really simple
give it time these are just principles
t3
today there's a tea called hoodia
gardenia which is basically an appetite
suppressant tea it's very very powerful
antioxidant you can try doing that if
you want to actually have it help you a
little bit there's other teas as well
you can keep very very busy because
there's nothing worse than you sitting
at home from the computer and watching
the clock like what am I gonna eat so
you want to probably get out of the
house go somewhere because that can
really help you find some activities but
don't just sit and at home all right
sea salt very very important because if
you don't consume enough sodium and
you're drinking water you're diluting a
little bit of sodium because you may not
have enough reserve and your tank of
minerals and that to draw on through the
fasting so the way that you know that
you have enough sea salt is that you're
not having any headaches you're not
feeling weak muscles you're feeling
strong but a lot of people have side
effects because they're not doing enough
sea salt okay I would do one flat to the
level teaspoon a day you can put that in
your food you can even make it mix it
with water some of it not the whole
thing and drink that down electrolytes
are very very important to for potassium
magnesium calcium and find one with high
potassium and then that will actually
also help you have energy through this
as well because when you make the
transition you need these nutrients you
also need B vitamins too so I just want
to throw that out there nutritional
yeast tablets would help you but that
will just make the transition smoother
the last thing I want to talk about is
just make sure that you prepare for what
you're going to be eating so let's say
for example you don't really know when
you're gonna eat because you're gonna go
as long as you can with until you're
hungry bring your food with you if
you're going somewhere but just be
prepared because what we don't want to
do is be like wow now I'm really hungry
and I have no more food because the
problem with intermittent fasting is
that the timing of it you know it's like
it's sometimes it's hard to time exactly
when you're gonna eat and coordinate
that with other people so have your food
available so you can go to the correct
food if you don't know about that I put
a link down below I think I up
uncomplicated the intermittent fasting
and I think I made it easy for you
hopefully let me know with your comments
below